hey guys this is a video request a lot
of you asked me to make a video about my
male model workout routine so that's
what I'm gonna do in this video now if
you're new here to my channel welcome to
DLM model lifestyle subscribe and click
the notification bar so you won't miss
any of the next videos I'm not gonna
waste any more time let's get right into
the video
alright now there's a lot
of different goals out there for why
people want to  go and work out some
people want to be buff big and "muscly"
some people want to stay thin but with
that lean muscle mass right for me I'm
somewhere more in the middle right not
too big not too small just nice
so my workout is focused on gaining and
maintaining lean muscle mass now I don't
have a lot of time to always work out so
I try to fit in all my muscles in two
days and then all I do is I just repeat
those workouts throughout the week as
and when I have some time so the first
day I usually start the upper body
that's my most favorite workout so I
start it off and I do about five sets of
around ten repetitions if I do
over twelve then I know the weight is
too light if I do less than ten let's
say four then you know the weight is too
heavy so you have to try and hit that
twelve reps all right so the idea is to
do the work out until muscle failure so
you really get the most out of your
workout routine and then you just rest
one minute between every set so you
don't waste a lot of time don't rest
four or five minutes don't chat to your
girlfriend on the phone focus and work
out all right so let's look at day one
day one is the whole upper body
workout I start out with the incline
bench press then move over to normal
bench press
or if I feel like it the dumbbell chest
press
next up is the peck deck
or the standing cable chest fly it
depends on what I feel like on the day
then I move on to the back exercises and
I do pull-ups
or lat pull-downs
next up is the lower back extensions
next I do the tricep rope pull down
and then the bend over of rope triceps
extensions
then I do the biceps with the rope as
well
or I do traditional bicep curls with no
rest between the two arms
and then when I'm done with the biceps I
move on to the shoulders and I do one
exercise where I alternate between front
and side shoulder raises when I do the
front shoulder raises my palms are down
an when I do the side shoulder raises
my palms are more inward
no to finish the whole workout  off and
to make sure I got the most out of it I
do five sets of push-ups and each set I
do until failure after this whole upper
body workout you'll know and feel that
you just went through a real workout all
right so that's day one now let's move
on to day two
day two I start with ABS
first and again I do four to five sets
and I do each set until failure first I
start with the jackknives and I use four
kilograms on my feet and I hold ten
kilograms with my hands just to get some
extra weight
remember your abs are just like any
other muscle group and they need to be
exercised in the same way all right when
I'm done with the jackknives
I immediately move on to bicycles and I
still have the ten kilograms in my
hands
then when that is done I immediately
move on to the elevated toe touches
without any rest to finish the first set
then I just repeat this workout for
three more sets
then I move on to the legs first I do my
squats and lunges together at the same
time by alternating between the two
then I move on to leg extensions
then it is the hamstring curls
lastly calf raises
that's it for day two right guys that's
it for the two workout day so all you do
then is you just repeat those two days
as the week continues and I also use
supplements because we all know that you
get faster results if you use the right
supplements if you want to know what
supplements I used check it out in a
video description of added them for you
now apart from supplements and the
workouts please know and understand you
guys won't achieve the results that you
want if you don't eat the right way so
remember you get fit in the gym but you
lose the way in the kitchen now if
you're still not sure what kind of food
is healthy and how to eat watch my model
diet plan video I added for you in the
video description so you can check it
out it gives you a nice kind of basic
guide to it now if you liked the video
give it a thumbs up subscribe and I'll
see you in the next video
Cheers